in the early hours of this morning
Wagner group's leader yevgeny pregozian
we can see him in the middle of that
video there he moved troops into the
Russian city of rostov on Don claiming
to have taken control of key military
facilities well in the past few moments
Sky News has verified these images that
have come to us from the Russian city of
veronese they've been posted on social
media what they show you can see there
um
a large explosion at an oil Depot
multiple helicopters as well can be seen
in the area separately a witness has
told the Reuters news agency that
Russian helicopters have fired on the
Wagner military Envoy